COMING UP AT CENTER ICE WITH TH.
SABRES KEEPING IT IN AT POINT.
MILLER S THE
NET.
FREE BY THE SABRES, TRYING TO
GET IT OUT OF THERE.PASS COMES .
RIGHT TO CENTER ICE.
THAT DEFLECTS HIGH AND ENDS UP
BACK IN THE CORNER AGAIN.
SKINNER TRIEDSE.
OF SIX MINUTES UP ON THE WING B
NOT OUT OF THE ZONE.
NOW IT'LL COME OUT AS IT IS
BROUGHT AWAY TOAGAIN.
LEFT FOR WAS IN WITH THE --
RIGHT OFF THE BAT, OUT IN FRONT
OFTICK LENGTH RIGHT ON.
VEJMELKA MAKES THE SAVE.
OUT IN
SABRES.
BRYSON THROWING THIS IN FRONT OF
THTHE REBOUND!
JUST AS THE PENALTYIN FOLLOWING
THROUGH WITH SPEED.
WALK RIGHT INTO THE REBOUND
RIGHT THERE, AND THEY'RE ABLE TO
SHUFFLE IT ANYWHERE.
COYOTES PUTTING A LITTLE
PRESSURE ON IN THE BUFFALO END
NOW.
OUT IN FRONT, THERE'S THE SHOT.
AGAIN.
TWO-ON-ONE.
THE
DEFLECTED.
DOWN INTO THE CORNER ITRTHER TH.
A QUICK SHOT.
WHAT A
>>> SAB
COZEZES AT BOTH ENDS.
SKINNER HAS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
ON THIS L L TO
KNOW THINGS.
>> I DON'T WANT TO KNOW EITHER.
>> Rick: IT THE
MIDDLE!
A CHANCE AT THE BACKHAND.
THAT ONE HITS TOO
MUCH LOFT ON IT AND PUT IT RIGHT
UP AND OVERHERE IN BRYSON, WHO
OVER T T UP HUGE.
PASS COM
TAKE A SHOT EQUALIZER
FOR THE COYOTES.
HE SHOOTS ONE.
ONE.
KIND OF HARD TO SEE THIS.
WE'LL TAKE A BETTERTHEM.
RUOTSALAINEN IS COMING IN FOR
IN.
>> YEAH, ON THE BACKHAND EARLIER
IN THIS GAME, HE HAD A CHANCE ON
THE BA ATHLETE ISN'T.
>> Rick: WELL, HE CAN SURE
SHOOT.
THERE HE IS.
SHOT GO
LOW HERE.
HE IS LOOKING FOR A FIVE HOLE G.
>>SSED THE NET!
BUFFALO WINS IT